So what I'm basically arguing here is
that we can think of reinforcement
learning as a kind of planning.
It's not learning at all.
It's actually planning in a kind
of continuous space in POMDP,
where the hidden state
is the set of parameters
of the MDP that we're trying to learn.
Now there's an infinite number of those,
which makes things a little bit awkward.
And so we don't really get the piecewise
linear and convex property anymore.
But it can be shown that you can
actually get a result that shows that
the value function in this
continuous space POMDP
is actually piecewise polynomial and
convex.
>> Okay.
>> It's not as nice as linear,
but it's still representable.
>> How big is the degree
of that polynomial?
>> It grows with iterations
of value iteration.
>> I see.
>> Yeah, so it's not like piecewise
cubic and convex, it's like piecewise,
it could be a lot of degree [LAUGH]
depending on how many iterations you do.
So this is still pretty
awkward to work with.
There's an algorithm that actually works
fairly nicely called BEETLE that tries
to approximate this piecewise
polynomial and convex function.
And can sometimes actually end up
learning very good approximations of
the optimal way to do reinforcement
learning for those spaces of problems.
>> Does BEETLE stand for something?
>> Bayesian Exploration
Exploitation Tradeoff in learning.
>> Which is cheating, I think we agree.
>> I think we agree, yeah, but
otherwise it would be like BEETLE,
which would be just way too hard to say.
>> Bayesian Exploration Exploitation
Tradeoff In Learning Everything.
>> [LAUGH] The E for everything.
>> Yeah, and then that would be better.
I think I could forgive that.
>> [LAUGH] Learning excellently.
>> No, it's too many,
that's just absurd.
>> The point that I'd
like to make though or
the point of the slide is that
there are Bayesian RL algorithms,
BEETLE is one of them,
it is not by any means the only one.
There's lots of different ways that
people have looked at actually keeping
Bayesian posteriors over the MDPs
that are being learned and
then trying to use that Bayesian
posterior to make better decisions than
you would in just reinforcement
learning, where you don't have
any kind of prior, any kind of structure
on what the possible underlying MDP is.
So a lot of people
really like this stuff.
It seems to, at the moment,
be on the side of just kind of too
expensive to be practically useful.
Q learning seems to tend to win.
But it's very elegant, and it's a useful
way of sort of realizing that planning
and learning actually are two
sides of the same coin.
>> We've used it before in
some work that I've done.
>> Okay.
>> But what we were taking advantage of
is the fact that it gives you
probability distributions over
value functions or
rather over Q functions.
>> How does it do that?
>> You're in a state, and
it just tells you basically the
probability of an action being optimal.
And that turns out to be very nice
because you can then compare various
sources of information
together because they're all,
if you can make the model
look like probabilities.
>> That sounds like that really cool
policy sort of merging paper that I saw.
>> Yeah, yeah, that one.
>> Is that you?
>> Yeah, it was by Isbell and
his colleagues.
>> Woo.